what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be showing you a
powerpoint that i made called how hot
not how hot
am i um so what this isn't asking for is
your opinions in the comments
um i decided that's clearly too biased
because
if i say i think i'm cute then people
come out and say the opposite but if i
say
i think i'm ugly people will come out
and say the opposite so i decided to let
the data
speak for me so what i did was i went
to a website called photofeeler.com
and i'm gonna put that link in the
description if you guys
want to use the tool because i feel like
as a guy especially on dating apps
um that would be helpful
anyways um so what i did was i put
pictures where i felt like i looked
unattractive um where like i wasn't put
together my hair was messy i was in a
sweatshirt
and pictures where i was like put
together i just wanted to see like what
the range would be because i felt like
one picture
just wasn't going to be accurate because
sometimes i do
in fact look homeless so um before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily video so the first i'm going to
start with the uglier pictures and go to
the hotter pictures okay
first picture i picked this one um
first of all i have like a bad set and
like this lighting's bad
and i think i look kind of heavy in this
and i think i was at that point like i
was a little heavier than i am now
um so this is the lowest
picture that i got so said for um
for how smart i look six out of ten so i
guess i look intelligent
go me um trustworthy a seven
an attractive a four so
i don't know why but in all the pictures
i
i look above average in trustworthiness
i don't know why
couldn't tell you but yeah so these are
the numbers that people didn't really
have any comments on this picture
otherwise
other than that they wished it was just
of me or like i have a nice smile or
this lighting was bad which it totally
was
okay so the next picture that i have um
a little bit better i think
um but again i don't have my makeup on i
don't think i'd showered in like two
days when i took this picture
um yeah so they said i look smart
apparently
a seven and i think people look smarter
with their hair pulled back i don't know
why
just a vibe trustworthy and eight see
people
would always rank me in the top like
trustworthiness
attractive um i finally broke the five i
made it to a six in attractiveness
which i was actually surprised because i
do not like this picture of me at all
these are the notes should have
one person yeah so crop her out
lighting is too bright that's fair
glamming up would help yeah okay
fair enough the next pictures that i
have
um is me on the beach i was a little bit
offended um
because apparently when you're in a
swimsuit you look dumber
so um smart this is the lowest score i
got in terms of smart they give me a
five
trustworthy is seven and attractiveness
a five um
i'm guessing this is because i think i
look thinner in my face than my body is
um i also don't think guys tend to like
tall girls
so i could see why that would be given a
five
um but yeah these are all makeup lists
not really put together etc
next we're going to get to the pictures
where i'm actually like dolled up so
um i was about to go on a date in this
picture um i was a little bit heavier
than i am now
but yeah so this is the picture
um they give me a five in terms of how
smart i am
six in trustworthiness uh six in
attractiveness
and these are the comments i would
prefer that it's not a selfie and i got
this comment across
basically like three different pictures
um
also would prefer direct eye contact so
look directly at the camera
you'd think that's just common sense but
i struggle you guys know i struggle with
looking at the camera
i forget um great outfit
and would prefer smiling more okay
so i could see that i think that my
smile is one of the best parts of my
face so
i could see why like the smiling
pictures would do better
okay so in this picture um i got an
eight for how smart i look i don't know
why i got an eight in this picture for
looking smarter but
um trustworthy and eight and attractive
six
it's funny because i think that the
second picture is a lot better than the
first one i just showed you
but for some reason they got the same
rating i guess because
it's the same person you know fair
enough um comments looks a little bit
sad
so when i took this picture i was not
sad but i was really nervous so it's
kind of crazy how that like
shows through um would prefer if it did
not seem like a selfie okay
seems a little bit too close up a less
distracting background and would prefer
direct eye contact
yeah that's all fair enough so this
picture
apparently i killed the game
i killed the game smart 8
trustworthy nine apparently i look very
trustworthy in this picture and let me
know in the comments
what is so different about this picture
than the other ones
because i was shook they gave me an
eight i went from a four
in the first picture to an eight and i'm
not even i'm like wearing minimal makeup
and a white t-shirt
you know what is that um the notes they
gave me
eye contact is not great i've gotten a
lot
different angle and would prefer crop
differently so those are all the
pictures that i did
but yeah i was just wondering today how
hot am i
you know um and i guess anywhere from
before
two and eight feel free to correct me in
the comments you know what you guys can
correct me in the comments i don't even
care leave a comment it helps the
algorithm
don't forget to like the video um
subscribe bring that notification
bell and follow my instagram while
you're at it just pearly things with
z i will talk to you guys next time